so let's take a look at the code for the
updated query so here's the query I had
from before i just commented out so i
can keep it parked but here's the query
where we get all the conferences and
then we filter by city equals tokyo to
get conferences where there are more
than zero but less than ten seats
available we need to add to inequality
filters for seats available it's okay to
do that you can't have any quality
filters for more than one property in a
single query but you can have multiple
inequality filters for the same property
so first we filter for seats available
greater than zero and then we filter
again for seats available less than 10
since we want to add sort orders we must
first sort on seats available because
that's a property with the inequality
filters then we can add other sort
orders for name and for months if we
weren't doing any sorting at all we
could just leave off all the calls to
order you only need to make sure the
sort order for the property with the
inequality filter comes first if you're
sorting the results at all and again if
you wanted to go ahead and actually test
this you're going to need to make sure
that you've got some conferences that
are in Tokyo with between 0 and nine
seats available inclusive as I guess
that's not that difficult a criteria
conferences in Tokyo with five seats
available